alright guys we are here with Matt from
kingdom trust we are actually recording
this live in front of a bunch of people
that you can't see staring back at us so
we're gonna try to keep this
entertaining both for those listening at
home and those here in person thank you
so much for coming yeah it's good to be
here
awesome you've got a wild story so let's
just start at the beginning know you I
think there's a lot that you guys have
done that people don't know so maybe
let's just start with kind of your
background before you start a kingdom
trust yeah so I was in the real estate
business before I started Kingdom trust
did all kinds of different real estate
investments real estate syndications
things such as that and then in 2009 was
when I guess the idea of Kingdom Trust
was born in late 2008 when we actually
put it to action in 2009 got it and
contrary to popular belief Kingdom Trust
had nothing to do with crypto in 2009
right no no I'd never heard a crypto and
so we kingdom was was actually founded
to be a different kind of custodian than
what most folks are used to so Kingdom
was founded to custody unique assets and
the idea behind it was to empower
investors to invest in through a
qualified custodian have the ability to
invest in unique assets that are you
know either illiquid you know
non-publicly traded hard to value hard
to store assets such as physical
precious metals private securities you
know anything non-publicly traded that
the larger custodians for whatever
reason you know aren't interested in but
but are still really good viable
investments we wanted to empower
investors to be able to self-direct and
buy those investments and that's that's
where the
company was found what gave you the idea
to do this was it something that you
tried to you know custody and asset that
another custodian wouldn't do or how do
you come up with this yeah it really
came through the real estate we were
taking investors into different real
estate projects and I personally had a
retirement account that I wanted to
invest in what I knew and what I
understood and and that's really what
where it began yeah got it and then
what's the first asset that you custody
it was a real estate I'm not actually
sure what the first one was I was the
first one to open an account so it
probably was real estate who was the
what was the conversation with the first
person not named at the humans who to
get somebody opened an account to be
honest when we first started the company
it was it was nearly two months before
the phone rang the very first time I
don't remember exactly what that first
phone call was about it wasn't the one
that took the call but but it was slow
in the beginning you know we we we
founded it from from from scratch so to
speak we we didn't have a book of
business we didn't buy a book of
business we didn't buy an operating
company we started with nothing and went
and got a startup as a start-up got a
trust charter back in 2010 and just
started beating the bushes and going out
and talking with people and and pretty
quickly physical precious metals was was
pretty quickly where we started seeing
some of our growth private securities
was probably the next we did a lot of
non-publicly traded reads and things
like that real estate actually is one of
our smaller and asset classes and but
yeah that's where it all began
peer-to-peer lending private loans are a
big asset class for us as well and
obviously now crypto is is our focus
and our largest growing part of our
business but we're still very involved
in all those different asset classes and
we're very actually very proud that we
have a very diversified portfolio which
I think anyone looking at a custodian
wants to see is someone who's all their
eggs aren't in in one basket so to speak
for sure well before we get into crypto
you know I you had over 10 billion
dollars in assets before you got into
crypto but I want to talk about two
things first so one is your building
company in Kentucky yeah which is not
Silicon Valley not in New York not you
know Zoo Gore or Asia I'm assuming you
started there because that's where
you're from but just talk a little bit
about the benefits and challenges of
building a company outside of those kind
of traditional tech hubs given what you
guys are doing today yeah I think in the
early stages it was really challenging
obviously and and it is there because it
was my home and as the founder of the
company I've started business in my home
town and we all sound like you're from
New York that's good that's good
so yeah there was a lot of challenges in
the beginning particularly when we were
smaller and unheard of and we were from
Kentucky which is not one of the
financial hubs obviously but you know
over time we grew our business and as
you said before we ever even got into
crypto we were well over 10 billion
dollars in assets under custody so over
time as we met people in the industry we
started doing a lot of work for some of
the larger you know some of the biggest
custodians in America actually refer
business to us because we we custody
assets that that they don't custody and
they had clients who needed custody they
would refer them to us so we we built
relationships you know through all
different sorts of channels and in
different ways and as we've grown we
became much more well you know respected
in the industry
and and I think also very well-respected
in how we custody assets is when people
learned that as a directed custodian
most people don't understand that they
don't understand
qualified custody as we were talking
about a lot of people don't understand
that but they also don't understand what
a directed custodian alright so let's go
through like a 101 in custody right so
just what is a custodian and what
services do they provide the market so a
custodian in general is anyone that you
give that you entrust to secure
something for you basically and you know
when you get into the financial markets
its it usually involves holding the
asset and reporting the asset that
that's the role of of a custodian is to
safe keep the asset asset that's really
the better word to use is a safe keeper
and then to report those assets in a
manner that according to the client's
needs that keeps them compliant it's a
transparency thing that came down
through the dodd-frank act so when we
hold assets we report those to the
need-to-know parties which in some cases
is the underlying investors behind a
fund rather than just reporting it to
the fund we report it to the underlying
investors in the fund as a transparency
that was all spurred through the Bernie
Madoff and some of that that happened
way back when so that spurred a lot of
those regulations so typically in the in
the financial world that custody is done
by what's known as a qualified custodian
so there's two pieces here there's
qualified custodian and there's a
directed right let's go through the
qualified custodian so I think a lot of
people here Oh qualified custodian is is
coming into crypto right or somebody got
the the regulatory approval they
actually understand what that means
right it's one of the things everyone
shakes their head yes I got it nobody
actually knows so what is a qualified
custodian why is that important it's not
a designation that you
that you go get and they and you get
this tag name of a qualified custodian
qualified custodian comes from the 40
acts there's two of them the investment
Companies Act investment advisors Act
there's actually two different ones and
we're a qualified custodian under both
of those acts and the requirement there
is you have to be a financial
institution in broker-dealers Banks
trust companies fall under that so but
you also still have some requirements
you have to meet within that so purely
having being a trust company doesn't
necessarily make you a qualified
custodian there is a few other rules we
don't want to get real deep into that
but so essentially it is a regulated
financial institution and when a
regulated financial institution takes on
custody of customers assets there's
rules regulations audits things that
they have to go through in order to do
that that is for the protection of the
consumer so if you use a non qualified
custodian they don't have those audits
they don't have those regulations third
party's looking over their shoulders
like we do as a regulated financial
institution and I think the reason why
it's important really is if you're a
large institutional investor the odds
are you're gonna want to work with the
qualified custodian or you may even have
to in your probably diligence process
for example because they need the peace
of mind around those audits and kind of
the checks and balances that are
required for custodian to meet those
criterias are correct yeah certain
advisors and meet reach certain limits
and and even certain products you know
whether it's SEC CTF C there's certain
ones who are required to use a qualified
custodian but it's certainly best
practice for anyone who is you know
investing other people's money to say
keep those assets at a qualified
custodian got it and then let's talk
about directed right and kind of what
that means because I think a lot of
people again they
don't even hear that as much as the
qualified side they don't know what it
means yeah and that's where it's really
different because we're a qualified
custodian and a directed custodian so
what that means is that our clients as I
told you Kingdom was founded on the
principle that the individual or
institution who owns the assets should
always control the asset which is very
much the same principles ironically that
blockchain and crypto has been found in
around so I have no idea how you made
your way to crypto so so a directed
custodian only uses the clients assets
only moves the clients assets only does
with the clients assets what the client
directs them to do we charge fees for
custody youyou see a lot of the big
custodians you know in the country that
I hear it all the time well they do
custody for free well they do but they
put your out your assets on their
balance sheet they go and they leverage
your assets and they'll own your assets
and rehypothecation switch is a big
topic in crypto today and they make the
spread on that right I mean that's how
they make their money and it's it's way
more than the the fees that we charge
those spreads are so it's you know we
hear all the time if that's the business
we should be in we haven't chosen to go
to that route and because we believe
that the direct as a directed custodian
sure if you want to leverage your assets
you can do that we have partnerships and
integrations with people who can provide
that leverage allow you to you know that
matches up borrowers and sellers and
actually you yes you pay us a small fee
for custody but you have access to do
your own leveraging of those assets and
and in many cases it's it's it's much
better for the client owns that asset to
be the one receiving the interest on it
as opposed to someone else so yeah so
the directed part of it really want the
key things is we don't put your assets
on our balance sheet we don't take
we take title of them we have to to be
considered in custody and we do have the
effective control but by way of contract
and through our regulatory the way we
set this up with our regulators we don't
put them on our balance sheet and we
don't do anything with those assets
unless our client tells us to and it
gives the client complete control the
assets at all times and there's nothing
going on behind the scenes that that
they're unaware of and so once you got
you know the qualified custodian direct
directed custodian set up start out with
precious metals real estate what's some
of the like weirder things that you've
had to cut I knew you're gonna because I
know you're gonna tell me the truth
yeah we particularly in the early days
we had we had really some we had a we've
done fire trucks which were actually
fire trucks that were being bought in
least which was actually a really good
business idea for the for the guy that
was doing it was very successful what
does that mean
so to custody fire trucks like you just
pull up in the parking lot we leave him
there or what do you do well there so it
was an individual who would they would
buy the fire trucks you know through
their custody account and and take title
to them so we would hold the title we
don't we didn't park the fire truck in
the parking lot and then they would turn
around and lease those fire trucks in
rural communities to small fire
departments and they were kind of at
least to purchase with a you know
basically an interest rate and I'm not a
lease expert but you know it these were
older fire trucks they were already
depreciated they would buy them lease
them get the lease payment then sell
them at the end and made some really
large returns through that but yeah
we've had people that have done you know
timber rights was a pretty unique one I
thought even foreign timber rights down
in Brazil in different places
we've had cattle we've had people who
were investing in cattle who would who
would in his basically syndicated
ownership and in cattle but that we've
we've done a lot of unique assets but by
far private securities physical precious
metals lending and Loan contracts has
always been one of our largest asset
classes and where do these customers
come from right so I'm just thinking
somebody's got timber rights somebody's
got fire trucks somebody's got cattle
Kentucky's a cool place but they all sit
in Kentucky or no we haven't kind of get
all these customers Kentucky is probably
one of our smallest states we we have
over a hundred thousand clients Wow that
we have in custody and and somewhere
north of thirteen billion and assets
last I checked I don't checked in a few
weeks or a month so it it may look a lot
worse today than it did
how much Bitcoin but so no it's it's
it's people all over the world and all
over the you know mostly in the United
States but we do some international
stuff too but who find their way to us
because they they want to invest in
things they know things they understand
you know I don't understand fire trucks
or I didn't understand Bitcoin when I
first heard about Bitcoin either which
was actually kind of a cool story when
when it was first brought to us
I hadn't heard a Bitcoin and I said well
then somebody explained it to me I said
well that that sounds like nothing
that's worth something and I was like
and it really didn't make sense to me
but but my comment was but I built this
business around allowing people to
invest in unique assets that they want
to invest in whether I understand them
or not is irrelevant and so we began to
look into it and I actually kind of you
know I got bit by the Bitcoin bug myself
and so it's become a personal
passion of mine I guess you for sure do
you remember the first person who came
to you with with crypto custody needs or
do you remember a kind of loss yes yeah
yeah yeah so it it was actually a client
of ours okay from the precious metals
world who is still a big client of ours
it's a guy named Chris Klein he's from
the digital IRA platform which is by far
the largest crypto IRA company in
America we still do all their custody
for them they came to us and wanted to
allow people to buy digital currency and
in retirement accounts the precious
metals market wasn't I think performing
really well at that moment and he's a
real visionary and guy and he brought
that idea to us and we started working
with him to build that out and
ultimately ended up building out that
digital IRA platform they own the
digerati platform but where the custody
custodian for all of it
and yeah so a lot of the early stuff
that I learned about the asset was
through him and folks that I met through
him got it into how do you go from pre
2015 no crypto business to you know
really you guys are seen as one of if
not the market leader and kind of you
know the tip of the spear when it comes
to crypto custody really on a global
scale how does that happen and you can't
say cuz you're smart no it wasn't it
definitely was was not because I'm smart
so it was you know we just started
building out the platform and hiring
people and learning how to secure the
asset how to how to custody the asset
and applying a lot of the same old
security and custody principles that we
use in precious metals and other things
and how do you apply that and we've been
through many versions so to speak of how
you do that and then obviously dealing
with regulators and
you know as we as we were maturing that
process in our company Bitcoin and and
digital currencies were maturing you
know through the 15/16 and and it was it
was really good timing call it luck you
know in early 2017 when we really went
public and and started promoting it more
and it was perfect timing for the market
and then we launched our institutional
platform in seventeen to start doing
qualified custody for SEC advisers and
folks like that there was a ton of
people pouring into that market right at
that time we were the very first
qualified custodian the first regulated
entity to ever custody crypto currencies
and I think probably by at least a year
maybe two
actually before any other qualified
custodian you know it's only been
recently really that there's been any
other qualified custodians come in in
the market so so it just grew from there
and we already had a lot of
relationships in the from having the
other unique assets with some of this
you know Swift some crossover clientele
you're out so so it allowed us to jump
out pretty quick and you know I think
today we've got over 5,000 institutions
and individuals that we hold crypto for
which I said if I'm gonna do some back
to the napkin math here if you get over
a hundred thousand clients and about
five thousand crypto right it's a it's a
growing number right but it's still not
twenty fifty you know 75 percent of them
holding the crypto but but it's still a
meaningful amount of the customer base
it's our fastest-growing asset class
before we have a whole team actually two
or three teams that are focused on it
I'm very focused on it as the CEO I just
it's it's a personal passion I love
where the industry is going so it's
definitely become a huge focus but it's
still just one of the assets of many
that that we custody a kingdom which
again I think is
it shows strength in a financial
institution when you have multiple your
assets spread amongst multiple you know
industries and for sure an asset classes
that let's walk through when you guys
are doing custody for crypto what
exactly are you doing for those
customers so we're safe keeping the
asset how we're storing it so to speak
it's which is a you know it's a it's
it's a it's a it's a word do you you
know people get an argue or do you store
be you know but without getting into
that argument we we safe keep the asset
at which in Bitcoin is the keys it is
the private keys that's so we we we
built out a storage solution we call the
icebox it's not just a it's Katie icebox
and it's it's not really it's not just a
wallet so in Bitcoin until you hear
about wallets and there is a wallet
component which you know a wallet is a
piece of software that helps you secure
your digital currency but to really safe
keep it properly and to do it in a way
where you can get it insured and things
which was which we built our the Katie
icebox was built around the idea of
building an insurable digital currency
solution so to do that you have to have
geographically dispersed controls and
you know multi verification multi
signature on the actual wallet side
multiple verification on the actual how
the transaction is built before it ever
goes to the wallet procedures so there's
all these policies procedures you know
roles that are played Geographic
dispersion to where you know ultimate
the end of the day what you want is to
where no one person or even no one group
of people can gain access to it and it
takes multiple people and technology to
to the asset or to move the asset so to
speak technology can't move it without
human intervention human can't move it
without technology intervention and none
of that can be done from any one
physical place so that you know so that
your physical security is less important
right so we spent a lot of time a couple
of years building through that we've
been like through V 1 V 2 V 3 so to
speak to get to where we're at today
which is we do now having insured and
insurable safekeeping solution so we
call it a safe keeping solution it's not
a wallet it's an entire process and and
within that entire process also is all
of the audit trails and controls we can
tell everyone who touched approved and
and it all has to move through these
processes to make that happen and we've
got that time frame down now for our
customers where we can make that happen
in you know a couple hours Wow
and part of what you guys are doing I
think as a custodian is you're
addressing the settlement risk and some
counterparty stuff may be talked through
kind of how you you know what that is
and how you guys dress it yeah so we
just in the last couple of weeks went
live with a platform that we're
partnered with called OTC X in well hold
on that was like an alphabet soup what
is that
OTC X in yeah so we were consensus today
we've talked with I don't know how many
clients today about it and have on
boarded a ton of clients who are
onboarding for this purpose and it's all
around we call it store it cold and
trade it hot so this is it's a
partnership between Kingdom trusts and
OTC X in and the client can come they
put their their assets into deep cold
storage the Kingdom and this can be
virtually any asset it actually doesn't
even have to be crypto assets but it's
really built around crypto assets at
least at this point so let's we'll use
Bitcoin as an example you come to
Kingdom you open and count you put your
Bitcoin
in the kingdom account and and then you
go out into the OTC X platform which you
join that's a very simple process it's
actually free I think on their side and
it's free on our side as well to start
and so once you join you you ask us to
place that asset onto the platform this
is all done through automation so to
speak and that asset is then put on the
platform so there's we already have
dozens and dozens of people signing up
this platform it's basically a closed
network blockchain trading software so
all these assets are held in custody at
Kingdom they're all verified before
they're put on the platform and all of
those folks have the ability to trade
and we're loading exchanges OTC desk
along with funds and fund managers and
it's all institutional but it provides
really really great access for exchanges
and OTC market makers to trade amongst
themselves to provide deeper liquidity
it it also provides the abilities it
takes out the way it's done on the
blockchain the assets are in cold
storage remove settlement risk removes
counterparty risk there is no
counterparty risk all those assets are
held in deep cold storage Kingdom they
trade and then the the settlement if
there's it's it's basically just book
entry on the kingdom in in so the assets
never have to move there's no need for
it ever to come out of cold store it's
always held and that insured cold
storage
the only time you need to have to move
it out of cold storages if you want to
redeem it for some reason which were
which is we can do and it's a
couple-hour process as we talked about
but it it makes those assets tradable
immediately so if you trade you know if
you have cash in your account and you
have
coin and aetherium you can go and sell
your Bitcoin for cash and you take that
cash and buy a theorem and you can do
all of those trades in literally seconds
behind each other without having to wait
to move out of cold storage or settle a
trade you know t1 t2 it it's really it's
really solving a lot of the problems
that we see out there in the market so
if this works which I think it does
right it works
for those homies looking at me like it
works dude obviously institutions are
gonna be super interested in this right
yeah I don't know how much you can talk
about your experience talking
institutions where they are in the
process of coming into crypto thinking
about digital assets maybe not crypto
currencies but tokenize securities etc
but you sit in a really unique seat
where they all need a custodian provider
and so I'm sure that you're on a short
list of who they have the conversation
with what are those conversations like
right now and kind of which are outlook
for the next let's say two years or so
yeah it's been a it's been an
interesting year on that front
and so in 2017 we had hundreds and
hundreds of institutions that we were
talking to and and and a lot of them
opened accounts and and and never funded
never you know we're never achieved
raising their capital whatever may have
been what we're seeing today is less
phone conversations but we're onboarding
more clients interesting or well more
clients that are funding right and
actually putting the digital currencies
in their account so why do you think
that is I think it's you know the wheats
been separated from the chaff a little
bit with the the markets where they're
at but what and I think people are
beginning to understand qualified
custody and that they need a qualified
custodian they're understanding the risk
of holding those keys on behalf of their
clients I think the insurance was was a
big deal and you know I know this has
been a down market and and
even at the conference today you could
you could you could sense some people
that were a little nervous or a little
doom and gloom here and there I think
you probably saw that as well but for us
we're not we're not in that position
actually the month of November was the
largest month we've had since we've been
in business at onboarding new
institutional clients Wow
so by far yeah it's really just easiest
because I've been talking a bunch on
television and writing about this idea
that the institutions aren't gonna come
in in the digital asset space so it's
crypto or took on securities on the
exchanges they're gonna come in through
ODC etc and actually the custodian is
that layer of the ecosystem is probably
one of the best ways to measure what is
that institutional interest right and
and I think our hunch has been this is
both through conversations so we've kind
of directly heard it but you talked to a
more stitute that we do even the price
drawdown actually makes it more
interesting to them than them chasing
something that is just growing
exponentially from from a price
standpoint
yeah it's I've always kind of laughed it
seems like everybody gets in when it's
high and when things go down
nobody wants in right and we've seen
some of that through crypto particular
on there more of the individual side but
my partner mark usko says people buy
what they should have bought and they
sell what they're about a need there you
go yeah yeah yeah Mark's a brilliant guy
so take take take what he says there but
we are you talk about our position and
that's really probably the coolest thing
about my job is we we do as you're
talking about these institutions we do
talk to most of them in some kind of in
some kind of way and have have accounts
with most of them to be honest and the
other really cool thing that we get to
see as a custodian is I think you know
nearly every technology innovator out
there in in the marketplace you know
needs custody for whatever it is they're
building their clients need custody and
some in some way or
it plays around custody and I would say
there's probably not a VC or a anyone in
America that sees any more of these cool
innovation that's going on out there in
the marketplace than we do and so that's
that I enjoy that part of that's one of
the things I really enjoy I'm an
entrepreneur myself so there is some
really cool stuff being built out there
right now around blockchain and
cryptocurrency and and and but but back
to the institutions yeah I think the the
ones that have made it are funding their
accounts more they're realizing the
regulatory potential issues if they
don't use a qualified custodian and so
we're starting to see more of them I
think they're also starting to see the
advantages of having a custodian from a
operational perspective in the fact and
this is partially things that we're
working on and we're building out like
the OTC X in and and many many other you
know that's really been our focus for
the last six months has been building
integrations with service providers that
can provide our clients with with what
they need so we really see you know if
you think about custody you this is one
of the things I see about the
marketplace in general is its fragmented
everybody's building a piece right
you've got all these these little pieces
and I don't care if it's if it's
leverage if it's trading if it's
exchange what you know there's there's a
lot of stuff being built out there and a
lot and a lot of really good stuff being
built out there but how does someone
access it and and and particularly
institutions you know are you gonna go
place some of your crypto over here to
do this and then move some of it in
place it over here to do that and at the
at the center of that is the storage
they all need storage well what what
they're beginning to realize you'd come
to the storage house which is you know
we'd like to think of as Kingdom as the
storage house and if that storage house
is integrated with all these different
players then you can leave your assets
sitting there in cold storage and have
access to all that you know people are
institutions they're worried about going
and putting their assets on exchange and
in a hot environment you don't have to
do that if you custody a kingdom but you
can still trade yeah and through
integration and platforms that we have
so you can choose to do that we're
directed we'll do whatever our clients
want us to do if that's what they choose
to do with their asset but there's other
ways to access liquidity without without
risking setting it on in a hot
environment so I think a lot of people
are starting realize you you you you
come to the custodian we don't charge
much more for custody than most of your
high end what I would call wallet
services do it's it's really and you
have a regulated entity that is
safekeeping your funds it has insurance
it has and it has integrations through
two different you know too many
different platforms that that allows you
to use these different services where'd
the name come from Kingdom yeah it's a
badass name so we're there from well it
was really built around build your own
Kingdom okay you know every every human
being kind of has their Kingdom right
and so when when the the name first was
kind of thought of it was it was control
your own assets
rule your destiny was was one of our
slogans back in the early days was rule
your destiny it was his kingdom you know
thing with like a sward kind of like the
old days but which is why I say our our
business model before crypto was around
and we were involved and it certainly
was really built around a lot of the
same ideas and mentality that that comes
through crypto as far as you know ruling
your own destiny controlling your own
asset
so yeah that's where it came from very
cool
let's talk about the future of banking
Rex I know you've got a bunch of kind of
unique ideas here in in what this is
gonna look like and you probably one of
the most aggressive timelines as well as
what it'll happen maybe just start with
you know how do you think banking for
individuals changes you know in the
future yes so I think it's a big change
and I guess the the way to start would
be to talk about the end or at least the
end of how far I feel like I can see it
and as you said I think I probably see
that here sooner than most people do
because I've seen the technology that's
being built and we've been integrating
and working with people to build some of
this so I see the futuristic Bank as one
entity where a customer whether it's
institution or individual can house or
store as you would at a bank with your
cash today
all your assets and I say all of your
assets literally it could be all of your
assets but coming in the near future
it'll be your digital currencies top 50
let's say you know you could you could
have there your public equities not on
blockchain just your normal public
equities and then your tokenized
securities which is all of your private
securities today which is the world that
Kingdom would was we basically built our
business around whether it be you know
privately traded mutual funds you know
non-publicly traded REITs or stock in
private companies or asset back tokens
that are backed by gold or oil or you
know some type of commodity and then you
have your cash right and your fiat
currencies which which could be I think
the one company we're working with on
some is has a bill
you do up to close to 100 different fiat
currencies and you have all this in one
place in one account that you can pull
up see look at on your phone and you
have the ability to not only exchange
those but it's exchange them amongst
each other right if you wanted to trade
your Bitcoin for public equities you
could or you know your private mutual
fund for fiat or ether or whatever you
know all these things would be
completely interchangeable and
exchangeable amongst each other and also
the ability to quickly without filling
out a stack of paperwork this big like
you do at your bank today but to quickly
leverage borrow against those assets
leverage those assets in different ways
and even do margins and things like that
all this available in this one account
and then I think they're really kind of
the most futuristic kind of cool part of
it is what we call the funds ability of
those assets which is the ability to
take every one of those assets flatten
them down into one spendable currency
that is accepted at thousands and
thousands of merchants so it's it's the
ultimate asset backed currency yeah
exactly if it's back it did it basically
you know you you you do it on your phone
let's say well let's call it a debit
card for the sake of something that we
can use it in analogy you you swap your
data car to spend your cash with this
you swap it and you expend your mutual
fund you swap it you spend your Bitcoin
and it's all done at a fraction of the
cost of credit and debit cards and so we
have a partner that we're very deeply
integrated partnered with who's building
out this technology company called vault
link I'm not sure if you've heard of
them or not
early-stage company that but the tech is
basically built kingdoms providing all
the custody and the fiat and and and in
in the background of all that and it's
really really cool what these guys are
building out and we're working with a
lot of different lending and leverage
pennies that are gonna be involved in
all this so it's it's it's kind of
bringing the ecosystem together and it's
bringing some of those fragmented pieces
we were talking about together and
that's been a real focus of mine and and
several of us at Kingdom trust over the
last little bit has been working with
the OTC X and it's a vault banks the
other guys out there that are are
building these security tokenization
platforms you know I believe that the
tokenization of securities is the next
big thing and and we're gonna be fast
friends because I believe that for a
long time people say I was crazy and all
of a sudden now it's popular and I'm not
talking about it as much but I'm waiting
for my my victory lap on Twitter to say
I told you so
well it's gonna come pretty quick your
victory lap is coming pretty quick so
what we talked about timeframe yep that
futuristic Bangkok it won't be completed
in 2019 but the basic structure that
will be out I believe in 29 do you think
it's like 12 months or less 18 months
okay the basic structure to be out and
including the payment system part of
that yep I think you will see in the
next six months major household name
securities issuers that people probably
never even think about in the blockchain
world are going to issue tokenized
securities in the in the amounts of
hundreds of millions of dollars in these
tokenized securities I think that's
going to happen in the next six to
twelve months and when one goes the
others follow suit of course and when
you look at tokenized securities it's
really I'm a common sense
entrepreneurial thinker I'm not real
super in-depth but you look at it from
the issuer's perspective it's all good
like you know there's there's no there's
nothing negative to the issuers in this
then you look at it from the investors
to who which is the world we grew up and
where you know when we grew up in
Kingdom grew up in where you sign up for
these long
you know lockup periods and all these
different things you have no liquidity
for five years two years seven years
whatever it may be whether that's
private equity or just a private fund or
you know whatever it may be and you look
at it and then you talk to the SEC we've
met with the SEC we met with the CFTC
but it's a win-win-win all the way
around on token on securities when you
particularly when you look at non
publicly traded securities and the great
thing for Kingdom is that's our I call
it our old world and then little did we
know in twenty fourteen or fifteen we
started building out the Bitcoin and the
crypto currencies we really didn't know
at that time but for the last couple of
years we've really been focused on it as
we realized with the power of blockchain
and that our two worlds are about are in
the process of colliding and we feel
like we're probably you know one of the
best position companies in America to
capitalize on that because it's it's
something we were we know a lot about
both sides of that absolutely before I
get into the rapid-fire questions to end
this thing I got to ask you what's your
outlook on Bitcoin not price but in
terms of you know we've had this you
know let's call it a shaken belief or a
little bit of fear given the price
drawdown but but what your kind of
outlook over next 10 20 years I think
it's great you know I think it's a I
think it's a you know if you don't say
my I think my looks good okay it's yeah
I'm not a price predictor and Kingdom we
don't we don't give investment advice
were directed custodians so we don't do
that but I think blockchain in general
is going to change how most everything's
done and I think that bitcoin is right
now going through what I what I expected
it to go through it I think most people
in the market expected that you would
see something
and some of them thought it would stop
it you know going down at six thousand
five thousand and now people are saying
three time I don't know but I know that
the the the use case is strong the I
believe in the store of value through
through Bitcoin and so yeah I think
we're gonna see another run I don't know
exactly when I would like to think it's
gonna be in the next twelve months you
know but I think it's not probably gonna
be quite as spiky and bubble you know as
much of a bubble the next time I think
we're gonna see a little more of a
steady up and steady down which is good
I think actually but yeah I'm a I'm a
believer in in Bitcoin and and long-term
awesome alright so I got a couple of
rapid-fire questions and at the end I'll
let you ask me a question which scares
me sometimes he didn't tell me how to do
that
no I warn you now and then we will take
one or two questions from the audience
since they all came here to listen to us
talking to microphones we think the most
important company in crypto is other
than the kingdom trust I start out real
host important company
the regulators we think we didn't
qualify as a company for sure we've
never had that as a dancer explain let's
say the SEC okay why is probably because
you know every company in crypto is
waiting to I would say very few to none
of them want to do anything wrong we all
want to do it right everybody wants to
do it right everyone's waiting for clear
guidance yep and there's a lot of things
sitting on the sidelines and being held
back until we get that clear guidance
and and I think they're working on that
and you know I'm not I'm not downing the
SEC when I say that whatsoever I think
they they this has all happened fast and
they've got a lot to think about and
deal with obviously the in the CFTC as
well so I think that's the most
important thing is the regulation and
and I don't know if that I don't know if
there's any one company that I think is
necessarily super-important perfect as a
great segue into the next question which
is if you could wave a magic wand what
one regulation would you change or
improve your to get your own kingdom
yeah you're a magician it's really just
clarity you know it's it's it's not so
much that you know from a kingdoms
perspective that we have an agenda that
we want a certain regulation approved or
not approved I actually can't think of
one mm-hm just clarity we just want to
know the rules
yeah so that we can so that we can abide
by them and build out our business to be
within the framework of those rules so
it's really just clarity I think I don't
I don't know that there's any one
regulation that's the showstopper yep
the main is there is there even any
regulation I actually don't think
there's one that's a showstopper as much
as I think a lot of people in the
tokenize securities were
that's where most of the answers come in
around either accredited investor laws
or yeah the hoops they've got to jump
through for going public or you know the
Reg D reg A+ type you know restrictions
it's all around securities laws usually
but but I think none of them are
regulations that necessarily need
changed they need clarified on how it
affects this particular asset class
right there's a lot of crazies that have
sat your seat you'd be surprised when
people want to change I won't name names
they know who they are I'm not
necessarily wanting to change them
I just want clarification around them so
that us and our clients can go do
business yep I think that's completely
fair what's the best book or the most
important book you've ever read the
Bible
oh no one said that before either yeah
that's that's my go to so yeah that's
that you know if you sit around crypto
all right what around crypto - I've
actually I don't think I've ever read a
book about crypto amazing I've read some
pieces of some books but I'm a I'm a
huge reader but it's mostly stuff from
Anthony Ponciano Jesus Christ I read all
the new you know I'm a news and article
and yeah you know those kind things but
I study it every day but you know a book
is usually one person's interpretation
of what's going on and to be honest if
it's a book on crypto if it was wrote
last month it's outdated anyway so so I
haven't really read any books around all
right what uh what one question do you
have for me before we take one or two
from other people here oh man I wish I
wish you'd told me I was gonna ask you
that before I got here I woulda came up
with a really good one too that's why I
don't tell anybody
[Laughter]
what do you see as in in the crypto
space what do you see is the biggest
thing needed to move the asset class
forward time yeah I think everyone wants
all of this to happen today I'm a huge
there's like five quotes right so these
are some people know a lot of quotes I
know like five so I'm not really that
smart but but one of the five is is this
idea
Bill Gates says you know we overestimate
what can happen in one year and we
underestimate what will happen in ten
yeah and so a tweet of the day said you
know bitcoin is almost 10 years old
right from when the network action went
live we're about you know a month or so
away from that and if you think about it
you know you got tens of billions of
dollars in market cap you've got a state
that accepts it as payment for taxes
right you've got millions of people who
have bought sold or hold and you've got
it being covered daily on CNBC Bloomberg
etc yeah exactly
in 2009 there is like less than 20
people in the world who thought all of
that would be possible in 10 years it is
if you tell everybody to think back 12
months you know 12 months ago this this
this industry was way different mm-hmm
than it is today
I remember we were at the coin toss
conference in San Francisco and which
was in September of seventeen yep and we
had a lot of monumental things happen
right around that time within our
institutional offering and man you just
look that wasn't that long ago it seems
like an eternity but if you look at
where where we've came when I look at
where we've come since then and look at
this the industry as a whole where it's
where it's came in that short of amount
of time is nothing short of amazing I've
never seen anything like it but I do
agree with you it takes time most things
do wise man once told me that you can't
hire nine women to have a baby in a
month
it uh I now have six quotes that's
awesome
I I appreciate you coming Matt it's been
awesome and I'll have to do it again
yeah it's been a great time
appreciate it